you look at 2017 with the price of
Bitcoin blowing up a lot of folks had to
start paying attention to this industry
with Bitcoin there's not this one person
who is the Godfather the promoter and
we're all saying hey we're relying on
you if you look at Shiba Inu you look at
Doge you're really are relying on the
founders to go and build the
infrastructure I think folks need to
stop trying to be the next Bitcoin and
they need to start thinking about how
can I leverage blockchain to build
something that people [ __ ] want yeah
all right guys bang bang I've got Braden
here with me uh I thought a great place
to start is uh you are a lawyer so you
can say uh you can give legal advice to
clients
um what's going on with crypto
regulation like it feels the entire
industry continues to ask uh we want
regulatory Clarity we want regulatory
Clarity how do you underwrite where we
are right now uh on that yeah well have
to to begin by saying I'm not giving
legal advice today and that My Views are
my own and not necessarily the views of
my firm but with that it's we're in an
interesting spot I I think if you look
at 2017 what happened with the price of
Bitcoin blowing up a lot of folks had to
start paying attention to this industry
I at that time started a task force that
was trying to educate Regulators I was
at finra at the time as an extern in law
school and I was engaged in a bunch of
different investigations of icos right
that were coming in through the jobs Act
Right crowdfunding regulation right that
were raising money on Republic and
whatnot and if you look at where we
started to where we are now we have made
progress but a lot of the regulation
that's coming down is through
enforcement right and as a market
participant you don't love that because
it's hard to have any certainty about
what you you can do and what you can't
do because all that you can really do is
see what the SEC is
deciding to reinforce forcement actions
and
so I think it's it's difficult but if
you're somebody involved in the space
right now what you really need to be
thinking about is how do I deliver value
to the marketplace right there's a lot
of different coins a lot of tokens a lot
of projects but I think you really need
to think about how do I create a use
case right through this project
implement the technology right but focus
on this idea of value and creating value
for for the community how do uh law
firms think about uh operating in
environments where maybe it's not so
clear exactly what the rules are right
and what I mean by that is like
obviously law firms aren't going to talk
to clients or even internally and say
like hey we should go break rules but if
you don't know what the rules are what's
like the framework what's the
conversation inside of uh various large
law firms that are trying to figure this
out I think alongside Market
participants alongside Regulators like
like there's a lot of different types of
groups but most people don't understand
how the law firms themselves think about
kind of where we are on the market I
think we've we start with published
guidance from The Regulators and at this
point there there are a lot of
statements that have been made by the
SEC by different governmental groups
about hey we think about these sorts of
products and these sorts of tokens or
these sorts of issues in this way and we
start to put together a plan to help
that startup or that project
find out where the lines are right
because it's it's never going to be
perfect right right now depending on
what you're what you're trying to do but
I think starting out with Hey listen you
can't raise money to build a product
product that doesn't exist using
investor funds and then promise a bonus
of tokens right we learned that the hard
way over and over and over again that's
not going to work so I think building
your project with you know is you can
self-fund it if you can get accredited
investors to be involved and be part of
the project and deliver something that
has value and then sell that thing that
has value you want to be in that
commodity space if you unless you want
to go to the Securities route and I
think you know if you're willing if you
have the funds to be able to just say
listen this might be a security let's
just go that route and try to register
you know you you may be able to avoid
some of those issues but most startups
that's it's is it a money thing is that
why most of these uh projects uh
Technologies teams whatever are not just
saying hey let me register security so
there's a couple things money as a
startup as a new company is going to be
a lot of what you're thinking about
because it's not cheap to hire these big
firms
um and the issues are thorny right and
then you think about disclosure and the
burden of being a registered security
with the SEC and what that means in
terms of ongoing governance you
it's showing your work every day right
everything that you're doing everything
that you're saying you're always being
asked questions you ought to make sure
everything you're saying is accurate
um it's it's difficult to do every
public company has issues doing it with
a ton of money so you think about a
startup trying to trying to compete and
play that game
um it gets pretty pretty hairy pretty
quickly
um but that being said you can do it
right and we have seen projects that
have done that yeah and what is the
current thought process around something
like Bitcoin like it feels like the SEC
the cftc and most Market participants
all agree that this is not a security is
that generally the the kind of
conclusion at the moment so that's the
other thing that's going on so you also
have this jurisdictional issue right
between the cfdc which from the very
beginning was like listen crypto their
Commodities unless they're not right and
they fall within our jurisdiction and
it's really plain and simple and then
you have the SEC that's saying yeah
sometimes but we really need to be
heavily involved and evaluate each one
and make sure that there's there aren't
factors because of the Howie test right
it's it's looking at investment of money
right with this Reliance on others right
to actually build the company and and
generate profits and you're expecting to
profit right as a result of those
efforts and when you see these promoters
a lot of times with a lot of these coins
it gets pretty tricky with Bitcoin
there's not this one person who is the
The Godfather the promoter who's saying
use Bitcoin buy Bitcoin and we're all
saying hey we were relying on you we're
relying on you to build the
infrastructure to make sure that there's
continuous value in Bitcoin to make sure
that you're making Partnerships with big
companies to accept Bitcoin with a lot
of these smaller tokens if you look at
Shiba Inu you look at Doge you look at
musk gold you look at a lot of these
things the the tricky aspect is that
you're really are relying on the
founders to go and build the
infrastructure and create the value for
the coin as the community and if you're
the SEC it's a little bit tricky because
you're saying well a lot of people did
buy this token in order to make money
they want it it's a security yeah
they're what percentage of the long tail
of assets do you think our Securities
first is not and again uh there is no
right answer it's just like kind of
given what we know now do you think it's
like over under 50 percent
I think definitely under under 50 yeah
okay wow I would think uh that you would
have thought over so why why under so I
wouldn't jump to the conclusion that
just because because remember the Howie
test these are all factors right if just
because you have a promoter that's
really active and you have this you know
this expectation of profit that doesn't
mean it's an investment contract
necessarily okay right it's it's a you
have to weigh all the different factors
so I would say under because it's really
difficult to say as an investor or
somebody who buys Doge or buys you know
one of these meme coins that there is a
reasonable expectation of of profit and
that that is the same kind of investment
contract that you enter into when you
buy stock in gme or or whatever so in
some way like it's almost like it's such
a joke and everyone's in on the joke
that like it can't be taken seriously
it's a it's for fun it's a community in
my in my personal opinion right this is
just my view is it's about this
community and when you buy a token you
buy Doge you buy much gold you're
joining this community you're saying I'm
now part of this community and we're all
kind of in it together where you run
into issues is where you have one or two
people or five people and or just the
advisors who make all the decisions
right they do everything and everyone's
relying on them to do it that's where
you get into issues where you've seen it
happen successfully is where the whole
community and that's where it's powerful
That's The Power of crypto that's where
it's everybody sits there and scratches
their head and says wow right because
when you have a hundred thousand people
in a community 200 000 people in a
community all thinking about how do I
create value for this token that's where
it gets special and it's not it's not it
can be a security at all because
everybody's engaged they're all part of
the process not relying on a promoter to
do everything got it and so like
when we see this playing out does it
come into uh is it a factor if the team
that created it ends up making money
like
I understand the expectation from the
audience or the the investor or the
person buying the token or whatever and
they're relying on the team but what
happens if uh the team makes money does
that have any contribution at all I
think that's where again right that's
where if if you're a regulator and
you're seeing that most people got the
rug pulled yeah right and you see the
the founders knew the right moment to
sell right and and they made a buck and
nobody else did that becomes Troublesome
because again it makes it look like you
really are in control because you knew
when to sell you're an Insider and you
sold and the other folks in the
community they look like investors they
look like people who weren't fully in
they weren't fully insiders that's why I
think Dows are really interesting and
the more decentralized that you can
build these projects even if they're not
technologically decentralized even just
literally having a voting system old
school old school put just putting
questions out to the community hey guys
what do you think should we do this or
this or this so this is fascinating
because I think I I don't want to speak
for uh um or over generalize all of the
critiques but I think one of the
critiques that uh has a lot of nuance to
it so it's really hard to talk on
Twitter and stuff like that is that uh
there's a separation between like is
this uh valuable is this interesting is
this uh uh a way to interact with your
customers your partners your community
whatever kind of group they fall into uh
with this um I'm gonna call like
Democratic uh type approach right so
opposing a question getting answers then
using that information to go change what
you're doing I think that like I don't
hear a lot of people being like Oh
that's dumb right like big companies run
surveys and and like like that's a thing
that has been around for a while one of
the critiques I hear that's like a
nuanced interesting one is like okay
but there's a difference between saying
hey we're going to work with the
community or work with the Dow or survey
or do whatever and then saying it's like
decentralized and you hit on this idea
of like technically decentralized versus
like a new type of mechanism of
communicating and I think right now uh I
don't think there's a lot of malicious
actors is my read but they're all
getting lumped together and the term
decentralized just becomes like a
marketing term so it's like hey it's
decentralized and then they'll point be
like because we like talk to the
community and like we get information
right but will Regulators actually peel
those apart and say like
decentralization is like a technology
measurement and the reason why I
separate those is like is there like a
number is it like if you have three then
that's decentralized or is it like 30 or
3000 or you know three million like
right how do you measure that and I
don't know maybe we just don't know the
answers yet well so I think you're
hitting on all the right points right
part of so The Regulators are very
interested in the definition of
decentralized
and partly the reason why is because
promoters of coins that they've come
across that's what they're saying right
that's one of the things that they The
Regulators have had to field right is
well this is decentralized and they're
like well what does that mean right is
it really decentralized and you have how
do they evaluate that as of right now or
your understanding so I think right now
the it's it's really technological right
in terms of but it's like nodes are or
users or something like that but here's
the issue so let's say it is completely
technologically decentralized right it
literally on the blockchain you have to
have a certain amount of buy-in to for
certain things to happen on the chain
and there's no one way for any
individual to circumvent that or change
that from happening
what about the servers that everything's
being run on is there any maintenance
that has to happen who's in charge of
that maintenance if you're trying to get
listed on an exchange who is the
individual who contacts that exchange
and says hey we want to get listed
interesting if there is a deal right if
there's a big deal with a company a lot
of times big companies will buy huge
amounts of different tokens and give
them away or do different promos with
them or accept those tokens after buying
a bunch of them who are they interacting
with are they only interacting with
through the exchange to buy those tokens
or is there someone even if they're just
a whale right that may be enough right
so you have to think about that kind of
stuff if you're just a whale you just
own tons but you you own so much that
you're able to actually your de facto
customer service your de facto BD right
is it decentralized in that situation
yeah and that kind of stuff I think is
just It's Tricky and that's why I think
you have to start if you love crypto and
you love blockchain you love Bitcoin and
you want to develop a company in this
space you have to think about what is a
real world problem what's a real world
problem you got to come back to square
one and you talk a lot about this about
building [ __ ] that people want right you
have to do that you got to start with
it's not just it's not going to do it
anymore it's not 2017. you can't just
throw together a meme coin and think
it's going to go to the Moon that's
investors do deserve more the community
deserves more so whether you're gonna go
the security route or whether you think
you've built a commodity Bitcoin is a
commodity it's proven right it's it's
not a meme coin right it really does
have value because there's a tremendous
infrastructure by being the first major
coin out yeah right and so I think folks
need to stop trying to be the next
Bitcoin and they need to start thinking
about how can I leverage blockchain to
build something that people [ __ ] want
yeah what's fascinating about it is uh
there's this weird
um maybe dichotomy's the right word
where uh a blockchain's entire purpose
is to get to decentralization because it
leads to security
um there are very few things that in the
Legacy world uh have decentralization or
this uh kind of robust resilient
security right that also are efficient
almost nothing right it's like Amazon is
super centralized hierarchical structure
like they stamp out all the bureaucracy
all of the the kind of waste uh fullness
uh and they just go for efficiency how
do we get something from point A to
point B as fast as possible as cheap as
possible and like deliver value to the
customer right and what's fascinating
about that is uh could there be a
decentralized Amazon like I'm
unconvinced of that specific business
because the whole business around
efficiency and the trade-off between
like high security versus high
efficiency seems to be like a big
question people have to make a decision
on yeah Bitcoin on the other hand is
super decentralized super secure but
plenty of critics would argue oh it has
a 10 minute block time or the fees uh
did Spike uh uh in past bull markets
before the invention uh and kind of uh
operationalization of uh lightning
Network and things like that and so what
you saw was like layer one super secure
and if you want to be scalable if you
want to be efficient you have to then
move to these kind of upper layers and
so one of my big questions I don't know
what the answer to this is but one of my
big questions is what is the real world
use case where there's a solution to a
real problem like you're describing but
can still be decentralized and solved
the efficiency problem and it's like
that's asking a lot of people to do and
so it's fascinating because uh it also
gets at the heart at what The Regulators
I think are asking themselves which is
like decentralization is important but
there's a lot of use cases where
actually probably it shouldn't be
decentralized which then leads to this
whole idea of like well then I think
people may have to register them as
Securities and like how do you do that
right okay guys you might think that
okay X
sounds like a new genius football
formation it's actually not Charlie it's
your new favorite crypto trading app
you heard the man
there were almost so that's why it
becomes interesting to think about what
Disney Central what does
decentralization mean right because in
most cases there will always be
stakeholders there will always be people
who regardless of the general landscape
are more well positioned to benefit from
the project Service Company whatever it
is than others right and I think when
you talk about Bitcoin and the criticism
of efficiencies in Bitcoin relative to
to other things I don't think that that
criticism is fair I think realistically
there's always a fee to use any service
you look at PayPal they charge fees
right and so Bitcoin is mostly free but
you may have to pay fees in transaction
costs to actually keep the train moving
and that to me is just fair it makes
sense I think it's almost inconceivable
that you would have a product or a
service or a technology that was
completely frictionless right that
didn't have any fees associated with it
because things that have value
there's something something there yeah
right in your entire time in what I'll
call kind of the legal regulatory part
of this industry whether it was finra
law firms the whole thing was there ever
a time where like somebody did something
and you all just looked around the room
and started laughing like that can't be
real because sometimes I see things
right and like I'm not looking at it
through the legal or the regulatory lens
but I see something I'm like that
literally cannot be real like somebody
has to be joking somebody has to because
there's crazy [ __ ] that happens and when
there's like less rules there's more uh
kind of a wild wild west uh aspect to it
is that also happening inside like law
firms and in the regulatory bodies where
like sometimes they're just shocked at
like what somebody attempts to do
I would say that the the kinds of of
clients that approach big law firms
typically are a little bit more mature
they have a little bit more money
they're thinking about things in a
different way right
um things are obviously moving at rapid
pace and something that seemed insane to
do right in 2015 now you might be
looking at it a little bit differently
because there might be new guidance in
that area so I mean there's so many
different projects out there there's
literally thousands and thousands I
thought for sure we were at the end in
2018. I was like wow how many more
projects can there be how many more
coins can there possibly be and of
course it's just continued to increase
um and of course there can be value in
all of them and some of them are I mean
is it ridiculous to just put a coin out
there on the ethereum blockchain
you know in East coin and just throw it
out there and tell people to buy it I
think so right I think you need to think
about how you're generating value for
that end user the person who is adding
that that commodity regard it's not
always a Securities thing it's just
about doing the right thing and building
something that's going to last right
you're if your goal is to send something
to the moon for five minutes and pull
the rug and maybe it'll work if you
build it if you send a bunch of memes
out there but if you want to build
something that's going to last something
like Bitcoin something like gold you
have to start with infrastructure and
start with value yeah it's uh it's
fascinating what's your background like
you you have a pretty interesting story
and I think that most people who see
your story would be like how do you go
from where you start to inside of a
Major law firm and kind of on The
Cutting Edge of these Technologies and
these markets and all of that like like
walk me through how that happened yeah
so I grew up in in okeechobes Alberta
small town outside of Calgary and
western Canada about 20 000 people in my
town at the time not a very diverse
Place only one of like three black
families in in the town and and so I I
dealt with a lot of racism a lot of bias
but I think my perspective on these
issues is colored a little bit
differently because I came from that
environment
um I grew up in an abuse an abusive
household
um things weren't great at home
um but and you know I was I was homeless
for periods of time
um lived on people's couches right
but I think what that created was a
different sense of how I bought evaluate
opportunity right I I look at
opportunity I think of it like a damp
rag right an opportunity and value is
like is moisture it's water and we all
grow up and we're given a rag and we can
get more and we may be able to add
moisture and add value to our rag but we
don't necessarily control how we start
and I started out growing up homeless
growing up in abusive household I was
homeless at 12 years old bouncing around
living on different friends couches
there wasn't a ton of moisture in my in
my rag but when things started to kind
of shift for me I wrote I read a book
called Think and Grow Rich yeah yeah and
like that book saved my life right so
for me I read that book at 12 years old
um and I started to think about my life
and my damp rag in a different way
and it started with gratitude okay it
started with instead of looking at
everybody else oil is big in Alberta
Canada huge and so I had a lot of
friends who were very wealthy it was odd
to grow up how I did we were very very
poor I had a lot of challenges but many
of my close friends and teammates on the
football team and basketball team were
extremely wealthy and so it was thrown
in my face right in a very interesting
way that I don't think happens a lot in
in America because I was able to live in
an area that was very wealthy but have
absolutely no money at all and not
actually have the the same benefits as
everybody else yeah right and so when I
started to kind of just be grateful for
everything that I did have that's when
things started to really Take Shape for
me so I got a call from a coach in North
Carolina who's where things started to
kind of [ __ ] for me
um his name is RO Russell and he was
responsible for for sending a bunch of
guys to the NBA Tristan Thompson Corey
Joseph right helped identify Andrew
Wiggins and me and Andrew Wiggins and a
bunch of other folks
um were got the call to join this school
in North Carolina what was it called it
was called Christian Faith Center
Academy and it was for me as I was
homeless at the time so like this was
like the best opportunity ever yep right
and because I didn't have that Dynamic
with my parents where they were going to
say hey we got to ask all the questions
about this hey I don't know if this is
the right thing that wasn't the
situation for me I didn't ask my mom I
told my mom right see you later I'm
going to North Carolina we ended up
there was there was a couple different
there was like a couple different
apartments and there were 16 of us
jam-packed into these these little
apartments where it's kind of all on top
of each other living situations how many
kids were out of school there uh well so
they're we the basketball team was like
part of a separate portion of the school
maybe there was a couple hundred people
total in the school okay
was had like its own curriculum yeah
what was it um I think Tracy McGrady
went to Mount Zion yeah yeah we played
against that school we're in that league
so uh Tracy McGrady I think there's 12
people on the team and there was 12 kids
at the school at the time and like they
got some trouble later similar deal yeah
similar deal because our school was it
was technically separate yeah and the
rest of school yeah but like big picture
is real Russell a bad guy yeah no he's
not a bad guy right he's trying to
hustle and and squeeze his rag like
everybody else is you want to give
opportunities to kids he didn't cross
all of his T's and Dot all of his eyes
did he get in trouble uh in terms of how
much trouble he actually got in I'm not
I'm not sure yeah certainly he has a
remorse about how it went down got it I
ended up like I ended up becoming an
All-American I ended up playing in the
Canadian national team I ended up
getting scouted to play for you know
better prep schools that were
established and different things there
did end up being an issue with my
transcripts from that school so I had to
redo that year right it's all water
under the bridge now but part of it
comes down to that issue of resilience
and how you internalize things that
happen to you I didn't ever see myself
as a victim at that school even though
we were literally we gotten fist fights
over food right because they would drop
over think about it you have 16 boys
between the ages of like 13 and 19. you
drop off groceries once a week
what do you think kids are doing they're
storing it under their mattress they're
taking it to their room right the
biggest kids are like nah man that's all
mine and you gotta like but like that's
how I had to come up right and so when I
think about opportunity
I see what's there when a lot of folks
don't see what's there so I saw that
opportunity as my my chance to get to a
better school so I was like the
basketball piece of this is real deal we
got Andrew Wiggins here we're playing we
played Mount Zion and I dropped a 30
piece on Mount Zion right there's
coaches in the stands yeah I'm not going
anywhere yep I was like I got this I can
fight for food I can sleep in a in a
room with four boys I don't care I'm
gonna leverage this and I did and the
next year I went to Wilbraham in Munson
which is a really really good private
school outside of Boston and from there
right got the scholarship to Kansas and
then but you always have to be prepared
for a punch in the mouth so I signed
with Kansas which was the number one
school in the country at that time dream
come true for me yep at that point a
total crazy story from homelessness to
where I was in North Carolina and I've
signed with the number one school in the
country yep everyone thought I was going
to the league right away and I spend the
whole summer there and what happened
NCAA rules me a partial qualifier really
because they don't accept the
transcripts from that school in North
Carolina really right and so it's a big
punch in the mouth it's like literally
I'm at the precipice of everything I've
ever wanted
of course I gotta make it to the league
now look at who I'm around I'm training
with Thomas Robinson and then Ben
McLemore was in my class all Leaguers
everybody right and so from there it's
like well what do I do and I had learned
though through my life up until that
point this isn't a time to internalize
my Victim this isn't a time for that
what do I do they were trying to get me
to go to ajuco because that's the
easiest way to get people qualified
get him back and I was like as a in
terms of academically I was a 1450 sat
so I was like I'm a better student than
that there's got to be a better way
right all due respect so go in the Juco
route there's got to be a better way and
so I decided to go to Fresno State right
I got going there the deal the goal was
to do like a one and done right two and
done what have you
literally a month before my first season
where I was going to be eligible to play
I break my neck in a car accident holy
[ __ ] this episode is brought to you by
eight sleep good sleep is a game changer
and the eight sleep pod is the best
sleep machine I sleep on it every single
night a great night of sleep allows you
to be healthier be more arrested and
have more energy throughout the day and
on the brand new eight sleep pod 3 you
can sleep as cold as 55 degrees
Fahrenheit or as hot as 110 degrees
Fahrenheit that's the secret of
thermoregulation better sleep better
energy get yourself in each sleep you
can go to eatsleep.com pump today to go
ahead and get 150 off your order
eatsleep.com pump not only do I sleep on
it every night it literally changed my
life and I begged the founders to let me
invest in the company hsleep.com go get
yourself an eight sleep pod and get a
better night of sleep yeah C5 C6 totally
destroyed yep they have to airlift me
out of there in a helicopter I just
0.06 percent chance of making a full
recovery wow the the surgeon I actually
had the same neck surgeon as Peyton
Manning
um Gene carrady he said if I would have
taken my jacket off if I would have
tried to take my shirt off adjusted
anything I would be a quadriplegic yep
right because any little move and you
learn this if you play football growing
up you learn if you if your neck hurts
don't move yeah yeah you lay back
straight and it doesn't matter what
anybody tells you to do you don't move
yep
um but I spent a almost a month in the
hospital loss almost 40 percent of my
body weight and to learn how to walk
again right and this is again it's a
punch in the mouth as soon as I clawed
my way back to the to the mat again and
I'm gonna have a chance to play it's a
Fresno State it's not Kansas but it's
okay I'm gonna leverage this opportunity
it doesn't matter Paul George just came
out of here I got this right yeah but
and Tyler Johnson came out of there too
and did great former teammate but it's
all about mentality at that point I've
now broken my neck and you already know
what's going on in the coach's minds
they're like okay I don't know if like
zero points coming back yeah that's
tough we love you buddy but I think we
got to start recruiting you know and so
of course they're thinking I don't know
what's gonna happen with this guy and I
don't know what's gonna happen to me
it's like the Friday Night Lights booby
miles he's like hey Doc am I gonna be
able to play again yes like I don't know
man right and he told me that and I had
that moment where you're seeing in the
doctor's eyes he's he's not pulling your
leg he really doesn't know yeah and from
there I came up with a new game plan
right it's again okay so how do I
leverage this opportunity how do I
leverage the opportunity it's just the
mindset of being a
Gravely injured may not make a full
recovery but still on full academic
scholarship as of right right now how do
I take advantage of that and literally
the only answer is okay right now you're
still being paid you don't get paid in
dollars as a student athlete but you get
paid in education so my goal at that
moment was I want to become the highest
paid college athlete of all time right
in education and how do you do that max
out credits I took 32 credits that next
semester the next semester another plus
30. the next semester almost 30 27 right
I had to write letters to the president
University that to get permission
because 15 is usually the max yep right
um but that it's dollars every credit
was dollars so I graduated early and
then from there again if your goal is to
become the highest paid basketball
player in College of all time
I always wanted to go to law school
let's make basketball pay for I
graduated early I had two years of
Eligibility left right so I'm just I'm
scheming because so many people get
taken advantage of by the amateur system
in the NCAA I I was the perfect
candidate for somebody to get taken
advantage of somebody who was supposed
to be this great player who gets in a
terrible car accident and now what am I
going to do go back to Canada and sleep
on my mom's couch yep until I'm homeless
again
right it's like no I don't have that
opportunity to be average or to
internalize this as wow I'm a victim
again can you believe it everything bad
keeps happening to me everything bad did
keep happening to me but it didn't
matter right and so from that moment
it's again I remember talking to my
coaches at Fresno I was like Hey I want
to graduate early I want to be the first
person to ever play NCAA ball while in
law school full time that's awesome and
the dude I mean not gonna name names he
laughed in my face yeah and like I have
to share that because it was one of the
most pivotal moments for me again yep
when someone laughs in your face man and
like truly from a position of experience
thinks it's funny what you think that
you can yeah they're laughing at your
ambition
dude it's testing yeah and it it
absolutely is the measure of a human
being what you do next and how you
respond and I was like okay
this is going to be harder than I
thought right because if he thinks that
it's that funny I have to think about
objectively and pragmatically what that
means it means that it really is going
to be hard because no one's ever done it
why is that so I had to put more time
and effort into my game plan to make
that happen and how I did that was I
started to think about what is the value
why would anybody let someone do that
right because there's a lot of downsides
if you let someone do something that's
never been done
if you fail you look stupid you look
silly the whole university the athletic
program you're going to say why'd you
let this kid do this of course it's not
going to work that's why it's never been
done because whatever you're going to
say athletes aren't cut out for law
school or whatever you're going to say
or yeah or it's too much of a burden to
play eight hours of basketball
and be a full-time lawsuit it was
ridiculous it was truly an absurd
um and absurd journey to go through
um but
I pitched it as well the value in doing
it is that what if I succeed what if I
what if I do succeed and maybe I'm the
guy to do it right and I had to just
kind of pitch them on listen Seton Hall
I've been through a lot and I've
overcome a lot and I don't lose I may
fail in the me like failure isn't gonna
stop me right if I get punched in the
mouth I'm gonna keep going and I'm not
going to make you look bad and I promise
you I'm the guy who's not going to make
you look bad and I'm going to leverage
all of the possible value out of this
law school education and being a student
athlete that I possibly can to make the
university look good and to make myself
look good and to make the basketball
team look good and the law school look
good right and you just got to take this
chance on me I'm the guy and luckily
they saw in me they were like listen I
don't want to get in your way right you
may be right you may be wrong but you
seem really sure about this I'm not
going to get in your way and I hope it
works out and I think a lot of times in
life
people are afraid to put their greatest
Ambitions out there there's a lot of
people who say you know what you do in
the dark shines in the light and stuff
like that I totally disagree with that
the Universe Works in a way that when
you put out there your greatest hopes
and dreams and desires and you work as
hard as you possibly can you tell others
all volunteer information here's all the
things I'm doing to make this happen I'm
not asking you for anything but
are you gonna get in my way
are you gonna try to stop me right and
that mentality I think is something
that's missing a lot from The Narrative
around a lot of different issues that
have to do with resilience particularly
black resilience and black empowerment
that's not something that's been focused
on right so if you think about black
lives matter it's it's polarizing
there's a lot of people who have a lot
of different things to say on both sides
and it it's divided a lot of people yeah
it's been important in terms of
awareness right I think that's really
one of the only things that it's done is
driven awareness and there's just a flip
side to that coin but without
undermining what black lives matter has
done let's think about what it hasn't
done 64 of black Americans in this
country say that black lives matter and
the increased attention on on racism
over the last couple years hasn't led to
any meaningful change in their life
which is
pretty profound yeah it's pretty crazy
stat it's like and I think it's very
surprising when I especially with folks
that I speak to
um both sympathizers and people who have
you know their own opinions about it
it's that's surprising and the reason
why is
celebrating victimhood
creates more learned helplessness right
so when you celebrate and focus your
attention on victimhood and pain and
Trauma and you think about millions and
millions of black Americans and white
Americans for three years being locked
in their house watching videos of black
people getting killed every day that
doesn't build up a strong narrative and
a strong idea about black people as
strong powerful capable skilled
excellent people in our society right
that doesn't necessarily enner itself to
the the right approach in terms of
hiring right if you're hiring a black
person because you feel sympathy or
because you you know you feel guilty
that's not why you should be hiring
black people or anybody and and you know
in a diverse group right if you think
about the feminist movement and what
made it really really
um successful was it was the celebration
of excellent women it was excellent
excellent women who were Geniuses who
were really great at what they did and
the whole world was like wow I need to
hire a woman right now right if you're
ahead of a company you're like basically
pattern recognition like it's the it's
the creation of a new pattern to
recognize right
um it's fascinating because I think uh a
friend of mine said this to me one time
uh their immigrant uh and we're talking
about
I think a reported come out it was all
about uh percentage of employees that
were born in the United States versus
immigrants and all stuff and he said it
to me in just like such a blunt way he's
like I don't want to be hired because
I'm an immigrant or be hired because I
did a great job yeah and and I just was
like I've never heard anyone just
explicitly say it in that manner and his
point was uh um I don't want to say
we're strong because it'll give it away
but like he was like where I'm from no
one expects them to be able to go from
there to a highly successful job in Tech
if I do it maybe actually people will
then say maybe I should go find another
person who's an immigrant from that
place right and and you create this new
pattern to recognize and in some way
like there's a lot of patterns like uh
one of the things that uh is like very
weird
um
is like the autistic uh pattern of
somehow in Tech uh people are like oh if
there's like an element of like being on
the autism spectrum uh uh there's value
uh that is assigned to that because of
past patterns that they have identified
and so you like start to see this and I
think what you're describing is less
like uh the sympathy component and more
of like hot it takes somebody to be the
first data point in the trend that then
creates the pattern which then people
use to recognize over and over and over
again right and to enrich and and grow
yourself yeah right so I think about the
Pioneer definitely benefits from being
the Pioneer absolutely and everybody
watching the Pioneers yes who came from
that same environment yeah I grew up not
ever I never saw a black doctor a black
lawyer black investor Black entrepreneur
just didn't see it right and that does a
lot that does a lot to you in terms of
what you think you can achieve a lot of
folks growing up in Black communities
see black athletes they see black
entertainers and there's is no question
if you ask folks in those communities do
you think you could become a rapper or
an athlete most people say yeah I could
do that right and but if you ask them
could you become an you know a billion
dollar investor do you think you could
create a startup that 10x is and gets
you know listed
um on the New York Stock Exchange or do
you think you could become an attorney
at the biggest law firm in the world
it's a little bit like oh I don't know
right and some of my teammates and some
folks along the way have told me about
my aspirations that that's white [ __ ]
that's white right me focusing on school
me wanting to become an attorney that's
white I'm trying to succeed in the white
world and that's [ __ ] right just
plain and simple that's [ __ ] but
that kind of narrative gets that
narrative is Created from the
celebration of victimhood and the focus
on it without
putting the focus on folks who actually
are succeeding because there's actually
a lot of black entrepreneurs and a lot
of black Achievers and lawyers and and
I'm fascinated with uh JC uh mainly
because
um
obviously he comes from where he comes
from his kind of early career is very
well documented uh now I think is very
well respected in the business community
and the investment Community people
realize like hey this guy like
understands what he's doing and they
respect him for the skills and
experiences that he's acquired uh but
then he still will turn around and he'll
use the music to basically talk about it
and in the new DJ Khaled song uh he
basically talks about like he says
something like you know uh there's three
billionaires that come from uh kind of
his uh group of friends
um him Kanye Rihanna and then he's like
oh by the way LeBron is also a rock boy
right so that's four then he uh explains
something he's like from corner boys uh
we're Corner boys with Corner offices
and this idea of like he still has a
very similar mentality of just like get
up every day work your ass off like do
the things necessary to be successful
but he's been able to transcend into
like a different world and I think that
he probably more so than anyone else
I've seen in music or entertainers or
anything uh maybe you could put like a
Michael Jordan LeBron up there as well
but like Jay-Z specifically has has been
able to do it and then talk about it in
a way that I think resonates with tons
and tons of young people and it's pretty
powerful he's a he's a perfect example
yeah right of of black resilience of
black Excellence it's and again it it
starts with whatever you have for Jay-Z
it started with music and he was a very
talented musician and artist and he
leveraged that to create an empire and
to become a businessman right that is
really really important because for me
all that I had I was homeless I
literally needed basketball it's like
it's okay I need it take it out it was
my ticket to get an education I would
never have gotten an education what
without basketball but that doesn't
matter it doesn't matter now right I'm
an attorney at the biggest firm in the
world doesn't matter that I that the
only reason that I don't actually that
when you walk in the room right it
doesn't matter right you're all you're
in the same room as everybody else and
Jay-Z is a perfect example yeah tell me
about the book you wrote a book on a lot
of these topics which I think is uh
fascinating because it's not just like
you understand them and you kind of live
your own life that way you also took the
time to write them down so that other
people could read them as well yeah I I
thought about how can I best leverage my
story and what I've been through to help
other people and help as many other
people as as possible and I think
there's there's a lot of stories from my
background and my experiences that have
to do with racism and overcoming bias
some of them have to do with other
things too but black resilience is is
really about
celebrating and focusing on
how
black people in troubled environments in
you know Against All Odds have become
successful anyway and it's not about
saying that racism doesn't exist and
that it's not a problem it's about
focusing the narrative on what we can
control right and I think about when I
break it down in terms of what I've done
and what many other you know black
successful people have done is they've
taken inventory of the things that they
that they can control right every one of
those times that I told you earlier in
the podcast that I got punched in the
mouth I took inventory of okay this
happened I can feel sorry for myself or
I can start taking inventory of the
things that I can actually control or
influence and putting together a plan of
attack to seize every single one of
those and and I think that message needs
to be related to more people there's too
many black Americans in this country who
have seen nothing but a narrative of
white people preaching at white people
black people preaching at white people
if you look at most books about race and
Blackness they're written to a white
audience that's crazy leave white people
alone for a minute right white people
need to have their own conversations
black people need to have their own
conversations and to the extent that
white and black people are having
conversations let's not have every Focus
conversation be on the focus of racism
and making the other person feel guilty
that's not how you're going to build a
bridge that's not how you're going to
build one Community racism is an issue
how do we solve that issue because for
30 years all we've done is appreciate
white people to tell them that they're
racist and it's not working so even if
you thought that that might work it's
not working we have the data it's not
working so I wanted to make sure that I
was putting on a message that just takes
a different approach right it's not that
I'm not going to say that it hasn't
solved anything what we've done over the
last 30 years but it's it's certainly
not carrying us over the goal line and
to me I think focusing on the black
empowerment and a huddle right I think
about the book is really a huddle it's a
black huddle where anybody can pull up a
chair black white doesn't matter pull up
a chair right but this is a black
conversation I'm talking to black people
the whole time right and we're talking
about the issues that are that are that
are facing us in our communities and the
challenges and the obstacles that we're
gonna have to be overcome and how you
might be able to go about overcoming
those things and be grateful for the
opportunities that you do have and how
you might be able to leverage your
career as a musician
to turn that into something else
leverage your career as an athlete to
turn that into something else but
bias is nothing but somebody else not
understanding who you are they just
don't get it they're not from that
position as somebody who's involved in
Bitcoin and crypto you know there's a
ton of people who are biased against
Bitcoin they don't know really anything
about it right except for a bunch of
propaganda that they've heard and so you
say oh yeah I'm Anthony pompiano I'm a
Bitcoin guy right there's a lot of
things that go that run through their
mind about what that means a lot of
those things completely inaccurate
because they're ignorant right they
don't actually understand it education
is the great equalizer right and so the
question right for you would be well how
can I make sure that I build a bridge to
more people so that they're not just
writing me off so I can actually add
value to their lives and educate them is
it going to be to say to every person
you're ignorant you're biased you're a
jerk probably won't work right and so
similarly if somebody is biased and
maybe a little racist whether they know
it or not is the best way to build value
for myself and my brand and what I'm
trying to accomplish to say you're
racist you suck you're a jerk probably
not it's about tact right it's about
building a bridge trying to help that
person understand who it is that you are
right with my professors in college and
in law school on the first day of school
I'd always give them like a little mini
speech I'd be like listen my name is
Braden I play basketball but I care
about this class so much I want to be a
lawyer right I read X and Y studies that
you did I read your paper on why I'm
super interested in Z make sure that
they understand oh okay he's not like
the other basketball players whatever it
is that they got going on I just assume
they have something going on of course
right because I'm not going to let some
I'm not gonna let bias stop me from
getting a good grade in this class and
if I have to you know if I have to kind
of swallow my pride for a moment and
give you a little mini speech and make
the first effort to get to know you I'm
gonna do that because my career in my
life is important yeah it's powerful
right right absolutely where can people
find the book so it's available almost
anywhere Amazon Barnes and Noble right
you can you can find it on through the
Simon Schuster website if you just
Google black resilience Braden Anderson
you should be able to find it pretty
easily
um and what about yourself in terms of
people want to uh to follow up with you
or kind of discuss some of the ideas
you've mentioned today yeah linkedin's
probably the best way to to me yeah a
big LinkedIn guy that's how we got
connected yeah yeah it's it's a great
tool to to connect with like-minded
individuals and people are trying to
build uh build great things that are
going to help people awesome and just
Brayden Anderson there as well yep
absolutely awesome I really enjoyed
today I I I think that um a unique
perspective on a number of different
things uh obviously crypto regulation
but but also just kind of uh the
different points in your life and uh uh
I I have often joked but also dead
serious of like we have a mental
toughness uh crisis in America uh
probably globally yeah and uh I think
the the ideas that are in your book are
are quite powerful for people and a lot
of people would benefit from just uh
just hearing them right you don't even
necessarily have to embody all of them
you don't have to say uh yes this is the
only solution but but I do think it's
quite powerful so I suggest people go
get it yeah it's about starting the
discussion right it's just about having
not everyone has to agree with every
single thing in my book or everything
I've said today but I think it starts a
conversation and it's a conversation
that we need to have in this country I
love it we'll definitely do this again
and I appreciate you coming today
awesome man thanks for having me